hi i'm jamie davidson i run the product
team at loker and today
i'm going to give you a quick overview
of what looker is today and where we're
going
looker is an enterprise bi tool and data
platform
we empower our customers to make the
smarter use of data
on the top you see the diversity of use
cases the looker platform can be used
to power from modern bi and beyond
and i'll talk about that in a moment
looker's platform
has a couple of key differences relative
to
the existing market our customers come
with their data aggregated from a wide
variety of sources
into a cloud data warehouse
looker has an in database architecture
that will
leverage the functionality scalability
and performance of technologies like
bigquery
and enable customers to drive real-time
data value from we've got a semantic
modeling layer
on top of that in database architecture
where an analyst
can come and codify their business
metrics
and enable an organization to have a
single source of truth
that that modeling layer is integrated
with git and version control and
allows for governance looker is a
cloud native bi tool and that means that
everything you can do inside the
application and more is accessible
via api that architecture has a
couple of key benefits
first data governance is is built in
from the ground up to because of
the modeling layer because of the
integration with git
our security access and authentication
you can have confidence that the metrics
that your
your users or your business is using are
what you think that they mean
and that the right people have access
that same semantic modeling layer also
serves to empower business users you
don't have to know
the complicated definitions for things
like gross margin or lifetime
value to be able to still make
directional
decisions based on that data lookers
a cloud native application every url is
shareable it means that you have
easy repeatable analysis because we are
we have an in database architecture
we are representing what's live in the
database
today and then in database architecture
allows
uh for for operational use of your data
because customers are now
replicating their full transactional
information into a cloud data warehouse
you can not just look at the high-level
kpis and where they're trending you can
actually see
the individual transactions that are
driving
over 50 percent of our customers now are
actually using
the looker platform beyond api context
to give you a couple examples we see
customers
using us to have embedded dashboards in
internal portals
so that their knowledge workers can use
data to make better decisions
we see customers embedding dashboards
into sas
tools like salesforce so that
the sales people can go and have
the relevant information while they're
making their decisions
we see customers integrating us into
existing products
and even creating completely new
products to
give value to their customers and at
times monetize
data and then finally
we see customers going so far as to use
looker
effectively headlessly so not using any
of our ui or ux
integrating with our apis to provide
governed data into custom applications
these applications don't look or feel
like anything that classic bi
would suggest it's beyond reporting and
self-serve analytics
it's really operational so for example
maybe a supply chain management
application where the historical
inventory levels and pricing
is is useful and looker provides a
governed view
of that into that application so lookers
looker's different we have a different
architecture too
and it gives some benefits we are fast
on any size of data we're leveraging
bigquery and snowflake and redshift to
be able to give you
real-time access to their their powerful
functionality
the semantic model means that there's a
single source of truth
for for your organization too and it
gives
the business users trust in in the data
that model is integrated with the
development workflow too that lets you
have uh changes over time and a life
cycle and management
for for those workflows and finally
looker is a
cloud native application too which means
we've got apis to integrate with
uh lots of operational tools we want to
be where the
the users are are working so that's a
quick look at what looker
is today i want to tell you about where
we're going we talked just just recently
about
the breadth of experiences that we
enable or use cases that we enable we
think about
the ability to serve those those use
cases in three real layers too so
the top layer of data experiences this
is where the business users are
consuming data
and taking action on it now below that
we've got our application
platform too this is what enables our
customers to create those data
experiences
and then finally the the base really
here is is lookers foundation this is
our our develop life cycle this is our
id this is our query execution this is
the core
of the app so to start on data
experiences
all right i'm going to talk quickly
about our core and you know the core
unit of a report for looker is a
dashboard i'll talk about
how we've completely rebuilt that
dashboard stack um and how
we're similarly now reimagining that
that the core explorer experience that
self-serve
analysis the expression of the model um
as well
we'll talk a little bit about how we
integrate into existing business
workflows
and then finally close on how we how we
help with content discovery so i
mentioned that we've been rebuilding our
dashboard
we've basically spent the last year and
a half completely rebuilding it from the
ground up
with a bunch of different goals in mind
we want it to be a more modern stack we
want to be more performant we want to be
more customizable
we also want to enable fundamentally new
interactions and experiences that
haven't ever been possible inside
api and that's includes things like
cross-filtering epidemic scales
because we have an in database
architecture and we can take advantage
of
databases like bigquery we now have an
interaction
mechanism too that lets you get full
granularity of your data ask as many
questions as you want
of the content when we rethought you
know the consumption of content we also
had to
think about the creation of that that
content too we want to give
our analysts a whole lot more control
over
the presentation of their data too we
want to make it easy
for them to create reports that you can
easily drive insight from and ultimately
take action on
and that includes things like
fundamental new modes of consumption
here you can see
a new report type this is closer to a
google doc than it is
to a dashboard it's still integrated
with the looker
governance it's still integrated with
our security model too you can see
it's infused with with data it's got a
live
look and visualization of metrics too
but it's it's presented in context to
and imagine
you're an executive consuming a weekly
pdf report emailed to youtube
the analyst needs to construct it in
such a way where you can easily derive
insight
from it too in a way that you'd expect
so this can allow that
we're also increasing the customization
as possible inside dashboards too
with with new dashboard extensions where
you can take over a tile of a dashboard
too
with pre-built extensions that are
present inside our marketplace as well
as custom extensions that you build to
to allow you to
create custom experiences and workflows
to tailor to your data
we're really excited about bringing
looker uh more broadly to as many people
as possible
that includes doing work like
localization now we now support
uh 23 different languages too for our
core reporting use cases
we are in the process of bringing all of
that localization to the full
application
um similarly we're looking at
accessibility as well we want to make it
easy
to for looker to navigate for all users
too so that everyone can
can derive value from their data we're
looking now
at exploration too and lookers explore
has always been an incredibly powerful
feature it's the manifestation of of
that that semantic model it lets you ask
lots of questions of your data
too we want to make it even easier we
want to make it so you have
uh smarter starting points so pre-built
queries to
start the question and answering process
we want to make it so that you
uh can do on-the-fly calculations and
not have to go into the model to create
new
new metrics or dimensions too that are
just transformations on existing ones
we also want to take advantage of gcp's
best-in-class ai and ml functionality
too
and integrate some of that into the bi
tool so that you'd have things like
time series forecasting to integrate it
into the explore experience
we want to bring data to wherever work
is being done
at a high level we want to drive more
value
that requires things like our alerting
functionality we've got analytic holders
that use
data to power workflows we want to make
them even smarter we want to use that
same
ai and ml expertise that gcp has too to
do things like outlier detection
where a analyst can come in and say this
metric is important to me let me know if
it changes and maybe tell me why
um and we can we can do that and we'll
be bringing that we want to make it easy
to take action
directly from within the bi experience
so this is building on
our action hub which is tightly
integrated with our semantic model
and it allows for interaction and
integration with third party services so
in this case
you could have complex analysis inside
the pi tool to find
uh over-performing campaigns too and
then take direct action to change their
budgets or
change change um you know
activity inside the google ads platform
we recently released an integration with
google sheets we're really excited
and customers have have adopted it
incredibly quickly
because they want to take governed
trusted data too
into a context sometimes where they want
to have some lightweight ad-hoc analysis
to customize experience
we're excited about this integration we
want to bring it forward we want to do a
bi-directional integration where
google sheets can basically pull looker
data in and looker can send data into
google sheets
we're also excited about integrating
with the broader
g suite products we've got lots of
customers that create
you know slide shows that are weekly
operational reports where they go
through a process of downloading a bunch
of images and reconstituting that
that slideshow or deck every week we
want to make it so that you have
live access to governed data in the
context where you're working
to to enable that data storytelling
within slides
or similarly within google docs we've
got a deep integration with slack where
you can send data from looker into slack
and request data of looker from slack
we want to make that interface of
requesting data even
easier in that communications context to
extending to
a natural language interface to that
semantic model we're really excited
about
a new native mobile app experience we've
got for ios and android and beta today
and we'll be ga over the course of the
second half of this year
where you can consume your data on the
go
we also want to expose that natural
language interface in this context
it's not enough to have your content
inside your instance though
if you can't find it it's not useful too
and we're really excited now that we're
part of google
the search company too to really invest
heavily in that content discovery
we're rebuilding our search uh
infrastructure
for a couple of goals you know better
performance better relevance
but also with an eye to to help with
some of the fundamental problems that bi
always has
if you don't have a piece of content say
you're searching for anal recurring
revenue you don't have a piece of
content that's relevant
we can automatically generate that
content too and give you a live look at
your total arr
inside that search context too the data
experiences side we are we are focused
on reporting and self-serve
uh analysis integrating with your
workflow and driving more value from
your data
i'm going to switch gears now and talk
about our application platform
this is where customers and partners
build
those data experiences and we're very
focused here on a couple of things we
want to help accelerate
value for our customers we want to
increase both the customizability and
power
that's possible inside the embedded
context and also extend the platform
to accelerate value we've released a
marketplace that's in beta currently
where you can easily find install
and manage pre-built pieces of content
so these can be applications these can
be
look-a-mel blocks these can be data sets
these can be custom visualizations
and they will dramatically accelerate
your ability to actually explore
one of those contexts and one of those
data sets too is google marketing we've
had a application and
a series of lookable blogs two that are
targeted on the marketing use case we're
really excited to leverage
the expertise in google to to push this
really
a whole lot further we want to help our
customers
be able to gather all of their marketing
data together to analyze and find
insights from it to and ultimately take
action on that
data too within the bi experience for
embedding we think that there's
a spectrum actually of need for
customization
and it sort of goes from you know on one
side there's inside the bi tool and
there's customization that's possible
inside
a dashboard experience or inside an
embedded dashboard experience where
you have themes so that it can feel like
the application's embedded in
we want to increase the amount of
customization that's possible in that
context
similarly we've got our our apis on the
other end of the spectrum too and we
want to
both increase the customization as
possible but also give you more out of
the box there too so we want
richer apis better sdks for interfacing
with those
those apis too and then even high level
javascript based components too so it's
much easier to be able to create
bespoke workflows too and customize so
as an example here is a dashboard that's
been themed so that it can basically
fit into an application to and feel
native
we very literally took our new dashboard
code base to
and packaged up the new functionality
and features two in a
javascript component sdk so that
customers don't have to recreate
filters or visualizations and integrate
them with our apis they can instead
take our our visualizations and extend
them and customize them
in any way that might fit their specific
workflow we're investing heavily in our
apis and
sdks too from documentation to you know
more robust uh interactions
as well and we're also focused on
extending what's possible inside the
platform we're really excited to talk
about the extension framework we've got
a bunch of partners and customers
that are excited about the potential
here the extension framework is is
the ability to host custom javascript in
a sandboxed environment within
your looker instances too and have
direct access
to lookers api so that you can leverage
you know
security and governance uh that's a part
of the looker platform
there are lots of different potential
applications i'll give you a couple of
examples to sort of
uh to show what's possible we've we've
released our first
extension i'm in our marketplace too in
our data dictionary this is
uh closely integrated with our our data
model apis too which can show
uh analysts and developers the data
that's present in the definitions behind
them
uh in a simple easy place we've got a
lot of partners and customers that are
excited about creating
custom ways to explore their data um
going beyond the pivot table metaphor of
of the explore page there are contexts
to where a more tailored experience
actually makes sense so
in this example the cohort tool it's a
very parameterized workflow
where you select a measure you select an
aggregation place you
you select you know the interval that
you want to measure cohorts on
as opposed to needing the full canvas of
a broad pivot table another example is
actually a hosted
notebook experience where you can
leverage the power of python
integrated with the local api too and go
beyond
you know what what a classic explore
experience would be really excited about
the application platform we're focused
on increasing the customization
inside the embedded experience
increasing the performance there too and
accelerating value for our customers
i'm going to switch gears and talk about
the the foundation or core of looker
here we think about things like our
software development life cycle and ide
for the data developers
we think about performance we think
about transformations that can power
that performance too
and how can we leverage the data model
looker's always been tightly integrated
with a development workflow
and we want to continue to push that
forward we want to have
a full uh quality assurance process too
in a single instance that allows for
development staging and verification of
development and production
environments and we want that to be
inclusive of
your lookout models of your content and
even your transformations in database
too it's in service of driving some
performance and
lookers in database architecture gives
us the ability to actually
uh drive performance in in a layered
approach
um we can take advantage of best of
class functionality of data warehouses
too and then also use
bi context to help inform queries and
drive
more performant queries we've got a
bunch of customers really excited about
aggregate awareness we released it a few
months ago
where you can create roll-up tables
within looker and lookers
platform will have the intelligence to
be able to dynamically optimize queries
based on
the questions or the the query uh
that's that's coming in so if you're
going for a granular
piece of information we can go to the
full granular table if you're looking
for
uh a summary we can go to the high level
rule
and to power that again rs2 we've been
investing heavily in our transformations
so
making them much more robust and more
durable uh we're focused on
adding new functionality like the
ability to actually incrementally load
into your aggregate tables and
integrating those those transformations
we're taking a layered approach to
performance and acceleration we want to
take advantage of the best-in-class
functionality like
bigquery's bi engine inside the database
it's an in-database cache
specifically targeting bi use cases
similarly
we also have a new in-memory cache as
well inside the lookup
application layer that eliminates the
need to do
round trips to the database to when
they're when they're not necessary
we think about analytics or we think
about administration a little bit
differently
we think about it from an analytics
first perspective we want to give you as
much information about the usage of your
looker platform
to help you drive data-driven decisions
um
and so you can use the actual
query performance to help drive
performance optimization you can use
the actual user engagement to help
better better captivate your audience
looker's data model uh and is is the key
reason why our bi tool is differentiated
is that integration with the data mall
and understanding
of the transformational logic that's
present inside we have a bunch of
customers now
using that transformational logic in
other workflows
or or use cases outside of worker so
we've got
a bunch of customers now using stable uh
roll-up tables too inside the database
to power machine learning workflows
where they've got
governed definitions of features for
their machine learning you know training
processes too that are governed by
looker but used in other contexts
similarly we also want to help further
leverage the the looker model too like
we're doing inside
the the google sheets integration we
want to basically let
analysts use the the right analytical
tools too
on top of governed data we think we
create more value when you give
give governed to trusted access to that
data to regardless of the context where
it's being consumed
looker in gcp firmly believes that
customers have the right to choose
they have the right to choose the right
infrastructure for the right problem
we firmly support that too we currently
support hosting
looker inside gcp inside aws and we're
actively working on supporting azure
we are also very focused on security
it's a
large effort inside our engineering and
product teams we've already got our soft
tubes
type 2 we've already got our iso 7 27k
and our pci uh skus as well
we're actively working on additional
security certifications
too